An incredible thing happened yesterday, which
is that the David Pakman show YouTube channel
reached an extraordinary milestone 800,000
subscribers.
That's an eight followed by five zeros.
We have the video.
It happened live on last nights.
Uh, Iowa caucus stream.
Let's take a look at the big moment.
Buckle in folks.
We are very, very close here.
We have reached 800,000 subscribers.
Amazing.
And I don't know why, but this has not updated.
How lame is that?
It seems to be broken.
It's stuck at seven 99 can you imagine?
Oh, there it is.
Amazing.
Incredible.
I hope someone records that.
Please clip that.
Please send it to me.
I want to post that to my Instagram page or
whatever.
Please email me that we did it.
Yeah.
As you can see, a riveting and very, very
exciting moment, but it also isn't this.
Thank you.
Thank you to the 800 now getting close to
801,000 of you.
Check out a graph of our subscribers that
I put together today.
I have some interesting little factoids for
you.
We've been building the YouTube channel for
a long time.
I went back and looked our first month on
YouTube, we had four subscribers.
I don't mean that we gained four subscribers
a day.
After our entire first month on YouTube, we
had four subscribers our entire second year
on YouTube we gained 3,200 subscribers an
entire year, 3,200 subscribers just during
yesterday's live stream of the Iowa caucuses.
We gained about 600 subscribers in a three
hour stream and we reached this amazing milestone
of 800,000 so thank you so much.
The next goal of course is a million.
We'll probably do something little for 900,000
but 1 million is really that nice round number.
Now, this is funny, weeks ago I started looking
at the numbers.
We were in Jan, you know, first week of January,
second week of January.
I was looking at the numbers, I was looking
at the calendar and I was thinking we might
be able to do 800,000 by my birthday, which
was on Sunday, February 2nd and as we were
getting closer, we were 10 days away.
We were five days away.
I looked and still February 2nd seemed viable
and we missed it, but my calculation was only
off by like 22 hours.
The new goal is 1 million by election day.
Okay, 1 million by November 3rd, 2020 it is
very hard to predict with much precision because
so many factors can affect this.
Right now on social blade, which tracks this
data, it looks like we're on track to hit
a million subscribers sometime between October
12 and December, so we might clear 1,000,003
weeks before the election.
We might miss it by six weeks.
It could end up getting pushed into 2021 depending
on what happens.
Now as we close in, I will fine tune the numbers,
but the goal, which would be so huge for the
progressive movement to have another show
enter this category in the millions along
with TYT, the young Turks, it would be huge
to do it before the 2020 election.
I'll keep you posted, but as of right now,
it's possible.
It's possible and thank you to the more than
800,000 of you that are currently subscribed
to our YouTube channel.
Really feels great to have accomplished this